there's an interesting instagram fact
called
hotness yoga it's where women wear very
tight spandex and do these
yoga poses and the shots are
shots are pretty intense oh man cut the
crap all right
the shots or shots of booties boom boom
and every curvature that you see
yeah here it's not about namaste
it's namaste and upon boom yeah here
stop trying to say like
well you see the posture is a very
subject
the girl spread out the girl a skinny
note
she altered there all her legs are part
out
stop trying to say that is uh you know
it's a bit
no that's what it is it ain't got
nothing to do with yoga
yoga is a way of life and their way of
life
and that'll be the whole life there's
nothing wrong with the
life you can alive if you want to you'll
be a little scatter
opinions cheese runner popping down that
is none of my business
you're here none of my business but if
you're going to be
and pretend like you're some kind of
natural sensible
human being but should not may got a
problem with that
sorry carry on just appreciate the fact
that you struggle with regular english
but that [ __ ]
is easy to unique can we all just
appreciate
[ __ ] struggle on like regular ass
english words but the moment he gets
into pachua it's like
you know the thing is there's two
languages that in english i my my my um
the way i pronounce is better like
regular english i struggle
but you know what it's also that that
accent
when i do that it's different whenever i
say these words it just comes out but
the regular english
i don't know maybe it's too close to i
don't know what it is i don't know what
it is
there is some kind of perverse about
taking a practice like yoga
um and then commercializing it which has
been happening for quite some time
but then also like sexualizing it in
this way
you know what i mean yes it's halloween
all over again what you mean
halloween was not what it was a pagan
festivity it was not something that was
supposed to be out there
to you know you would just as the dead
you would dress
to commemorate the dead not sexy nurse
sexy pikachu it's a bit halloween all
over again
so what are your thoughts on the whole
matter like the whole wing thing i don't
care about it
you want to hold you on your whole face
and i'm talking guys or girls
whether it's a girl that is out there
doing yoga poses in
in in in leggings or skin tone leggings
or whatever
or a man with is uh
banana right there uh on the picture you
know
abs and everything and stuff i don't i
don't have a problem with y'all on that
phase
but if you use let's work out good and
it's not about working out
you don't give no information about your
working out it's just
50 shades of you posing in a suggested
suggestive way
it's that's not the point it's not yoga
you're not doing this for your yoga
you're not doing this for the way of
life you're not doing this
to be flexible you're doing this to show
people
people that you're flexible you know
what i mean so that's the thing
i'm like yo i'm not i'm not buying into
this
look i made my nails today and there's
just a big old
picture of your booty that no you want
to show your booty
show your booty but don't try to make me
think that it's some kind of other thing
that you're trying to show
it's just if you want to do it do it but
it's just it's just come on now we know
why you're doing there's no information
panda poses there's no information
i'd rather have someone that's like yo
you know what
whole face i'm just gonna expose myself
like that
then you try to sell it to me in some
kind of package that it's not it's
this is come on it's not that it ain't
it it ain't it
bait it's just super baby it's just
super cringe to me i hate all the being
me and myself and others receive but i
will admit
i definitely look very awkward in this
picture
the [ __ ] outta here take all your sh
get out it ain't about bullying it ain't
about come on now
with the quotes the quote is the quotes
for me
it's a quote you try to put a cute quote
it's not because you put a quote
on a picture of you that you really
oh it's just man no do i look like
aquaman or is it just me you don't look
like aquaman
you know it ain't got nothing to do with
this like oh yo
uh to me it's just cringe but there's a
lot of people that like that do you boo
boo but it's cringe
i don't know man i don't know why i take
off like it's calling me stupid in my
face everyone knows what's going on
there's just an interesting irony
between like what yoga preaches and
practices
and then what she's exposing and what
she's showcasing
yes you know what i mean that's that's
the only weird thing i'd be like hey man
this is the best muslim in the world
while like i'm
biting into a live pic it's just like
the amount of haram that's happening on
screen right now while i'm trying to do
that it's just crazy to me sometimes
people send me like instagram pages to
look at and like or like the fetal
recommend me stuff and i just i cringe
so often
someone raised an interesting question
they said would you ever consider dating
beautiful women like this i'm like no
what does it have to do with the beauty
how much you willing to tolerate because
they're hot no because you don't have to
tolerate
because they're hot i mean i don't care
if she's beautiful or not but people do
yes people do but i wouldn't care it's
not it's not about that
it's not about how beautiful she is
that's not even the conversation
and what makes it cringe it's not the
hotness it's the rest of it
yes but basically it's like are you
willing to overlook
what she's doing because she's very
attractive
no at the end of the day this is about
her being attractive
yeah because this page wouldn't be
popping if her ass wasn't popping
no that wouldn't remember wouldn't be
popping like that exactly so
that does play a factor in all this and
the whole instagram scene kind of weirds
me out whether it's like male or females
with the whole
with everyone putting their stuff out
there i'm just like
you know i struggle with this whole
conversation for a hot minute but
something about this one in particular
this fad is just awkward to me
you want to put a picture of you looking
good put a picture of you looking good
don't try to make get past like it's
some right it's not
it's for your ego you're boosting your
ego don't don't say oh
love my baptism [ __ ] pouring holy
water on yourself that's like
running down between your breasts it's
like
okay you know for you it's fine that
it's for your ego but don't try to make
it past like something else
and try to put up just be shameless i'll
quote that don't be famous
but anyways tell us what you guys think
why do you guys feel in the comments
below
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]